vas-y que je pétris la pâte vas-y que je
fais le couscous vas-y que je leur fais
des boulettes vas-y que je le fais quoi
vous en avait marre des boulettes he
voilà des
keftas il faut
éliminer les calories de là de là de
là non c'est vrai
moi quand je suis stressé soit je danse
soit je je grignote je grignotte oui
mais vous comprenez pas que je flippe
oui je flippe c'est normal c'est la fête
des mères aujourd'hui la fête des mère
et ben toute la famille va débarquer
pour bouffer et qui c'est qui va
organiser la couscous partie c'est bibi
alors vas-y que je pétris la pâte vas-y
que je fa le couscous vas-y que je leur
fais des boulettes vas-y que je leur
fais quoi vous en avez marre des
boulettes he voilà des
keftas allez mets au four enlève du four
une chaleur de folie le maquillage il
était pas waterproof il a tout dégouliné
enfin c'est pas grave je me demande
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont m'offrir cette
année l'année dernière ils m'ont offert
un coussecoussier imitation Chanel avec
le jogging
àorti mais sur le jogging il s'était
trompé il avait marqué ch
tu me vois sortir avec jogging écrit
Chamel qu'est-ce qu'il y avait encore il
y avait un P personne électronique
parlant ah oui parle quand je suis monté
dessus il a
dit allez venez que la fête commence
allez allez allez allez allez allez un
peu plus vite la grosse allez
allez voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parfait